so in one word I'm going to hold you to
this might be kind of a tough question
to ask a fashion designer but what in
one word would describe your
professional style my professional style
correct if I got more than one word but
let's shop I'm here in Manhattan's
garment district with Carly cushiony
who's half of the team here at cushiony
and Oaks if I saying that right or is it
ox ox cushiony an ox was cleverly if you
put it together it says CEO so that's
nice and this is a fashion company you
started a few years ago yeah we started
in 2008 so it's just a little bit yeah
five years next year and you've met your
your co-founder while studying here in
New York yeah I came from London and I
came and started at Parsons and that's
why we met in junior year and how did
you get the idea to start a I mean most
of it wasn't with people in college even
design schools like Parsons are just
trying to through they're not thinking
about starting their own companies
actually we didn't even think about that
either when we were at Parsons we were
never thinking about okay let's do
something together let's start something
right away
we figured we'd either finish school and
then go get a job and even our senior
thesis project where you have to design
and make a collection we did that
separately you know a lot of students do
pair up and you know do a collaborative
thing and we didn't we were just really
really good friends and we had like a
similar design aesthetic and and just
were really close and then it was after
that that we really talked about you
know doing something together and we you
know thought about this niche that we
thought we could fill and what would you
call this how would you describe it
well our aesthetic in general is it's
it's very sexy but strong with a sort of
minimal edge so we felt like you know
there wasn't clothing out there that for
a sophisticated woman that wanted to be
sexy without being vulgar and we really
wanted to express these clean lines that
we had and really focusing on the female
body you are you wearing your
yeah it looks fantastic and you had some
success with some celebrity people
pretty close to out of the box right
Jessica Alba and yeah we've just um
we've dressed a lot a lot of celebrities
now we've become pretty well-known for
red carpet cocktail dress we're up some
names we've dressed so Jessica Alba Eva
Longoria Rihanna Reese Witherspoon Liz
Hurley perhaps the biggest name of all
Michelle Obama Michelle Obama it's
always I'd like to see your clothing on
Michelle Obama that was pretty
incredible you never you know you always
you never know if it's gonna happen they
say okay she might wear it on this date
and that was a shootin coming here and
you didn't know I don't know we never
got to meet but um you never know if
these things gonna happen if if they're
gonna end up wearing it you know they
and and you know we got a text from our
publicist and said she's fantastic
so that was really really exciting and
it really does give you so much exposure
because I mean Michelle Obama she's the
ultimate celebrity she's an you know and
it really opened doors for us
internationally in terms of stories and
stuff so what was your sort of see that
you graduated you guys decided we're
gonna try and do this and what was sort
of the first thing when you realized
this wasn't just a project you were
doing with with your friend that it was
that this was gonna be a real company
that was something that you know really
grow I think starting it so young I
think that was kind of a blessing in
disguise slightly naively going into it
um and so you know it started very slow
and then you know we did our first
collection with spring o 9 and then it
just suddenly just kept going through
sort of sale was there certain was
something that made it feel more real I
mean it had to be real at that PI mean
we what offers collection we were
exclusive to Bergdorf's and Linda Fargo
at Bergdorf had been you know really
supportive to us throughout our thesis
was you knew
we met her during our thesis judging
panel she's one of the judges and so we
kept relationship with her and then and
then told her that you know we were
thinking about doing a line together and
you know what do you think and and so
you know then we continuing to build
this all up and it gets to a point where
you really there's no turning back so
and then once we went exclusive with
them it was fantastic I mean they're
still our biggest distributor and we
have a great relationship what other
stores can people find your stuff um
we're at Saks and Neiman's as well as
other boutiques around the states like
Stanley korshack and we also sell in
London and Harvey Nichols in Hong Kong
and Harvey Nichols and in other places
in Asia and the Middle East as well so
if I come back here in five years what
about everyone I'm gonna say I'm in the
middle of a huge bustling factory or are
we gonna still sort of be boutique you
or what's your goal our goal is still to
grow and still but sensibly not go crazy
we do want to become a lifestyle brand
and offer our customer shoes and
handbags and full range of accessories
so we do want to expand to a full
collection so what would be the first
step beyond clothes you think first step
well we did actually just launch
swimwear this past spring collection but
then it'll be shoes and bags after that